[Applause]
the last thing she said was from
somebody she can't control yeah that is
your problem no whose actions I can't
control anything
you need to control yourself listen and
I do and that's why I said I would
rather be in a situation where I can
control myself and not have to be
audited why wouldn't you just not have
if you want to make life about you and
what you want don't have kids but it's
not about what me and what I want I know
that's what I'm saying it is
wait okay if you if you're putting your
feelings above the kid so if you're
saying you know because I don't want to
get along with a man that I can't
control his actions your words your
words okay so so because you're putting
your feelings above what's best for a
child so if that's what you want to do
then why would you have a child okay
I'll repeat exactly what I said again as
a woman I am very nurturing and I would
be a great a great mother I know that I
don't know listen I don't need anyone to
to tell me this or not because none of
you actually know me in my private life
in my personal life which means never
yes wait wait no you don't actually you
don't you actually don't you know you
actually don't you really don't know
what I do on a daily basis and that's
why I say for me what I am thinking of
the child because I would rather have a
very healthy relationship with somebody
that I have a child with that is not
based on possession or having to try and
get on I don't want to have to do that
because the friction is going to go on
the kids so instead my main focus will
be on keeping myself happy so I can give
the best that I am to my child
but does that child need two parents
yeah and they'll have two parents I'm
not going to take the child away from
them do you understand them and the
thing is we've spoken about this on the
show on multiple occasions that you put
your child at every statistical
disadvantage when you choose to become a
single mother I'm choosing to become a
single woman now hang on but you're
choosing to have to raise a child in a
household without a man okay so your
child is more likely to be homeless your
child is more likely to go to prison
your child is more likely to have mental
issues your child is more likely to be a
an angry Grapist he's more likely to be
in a gang she he or she
can children that come from single
parent households specifically single
mother households are subject to all of
those things okay
and it can range from 60 of the children
you need more detail to my story then to
Aims at the children
like the fact that you would choose that
um
can I just say something right because I
like to go by what I know I don't know
about stats and all that
this man here
was in a relationship thought they'd be
forever it got messed up he's not
co-parenting would he have chose to be a
co-parent in the beginning no no you're
going out there and you're choosing the
only reason why he's co-parenting
because he knows that my co-parenting
with his child's mother will put his
child at an advantage but otherwise
after doing what you're doing you're
putting your child at a disadvantage but
this is a guy that's been there done it
got the t-shirt and you still won't
listen selfies so previous instead of
instead of fully and falling for the
Trap like he did of going through
somebody that you didn't get on in the
end and now you're comparing probably
having friction
wait wait let me land I would rather go
from the beginning and say okay we're
gonna have a baby it's like yeah girl
we're gonna have a baby we have the baby
[ __ ] and you come to your side I go to
my side and we go parents
no woman is the one that stays with the
baby anyway that's wrong because women
like you
and this is why I said somebody that is
a good friend to me somebody that's
because there's a respect I will never
take somebody and my child away from
from a parent from his father you're
doing that no I'm not let me do it no
because you keep shouting instead of
trying to do this
you've been explaining for ages and ages
and ages it don't make no sense you're
not listening but you want everyone to
listen to you you've got him there
telling you like the women they're
telling you
you've got here
listen you're not saying what I'm saying
you're choosing to try yourself
rather than just spend the time healing
yourself so you can go into relationship
potentially with a friend and actually
allow yourself to learn how to be loved
How To Love Yourself
baby you're just going to be passing the
same trauma pattern that was probably
possible
onto your child
let me tell you something you'd rather
not be with anyone
can we just rewind before this got mad
deep yeah yes you made this whole point
about our guys that you've got that are
friends that in the friend zone yeah and
they don't move out the friend zone
because they're your friends they will
never step out but this whole argument
started because you said
when you decide to have a kid you'll
just pick one at the friend zone so you
contradict yourself straight away okay
I'll explain myself let's go again so
let me explain your contradiction
explain the contradiction what I want my
ideal situation is to have a man that I
meet with respect each other Beyond
really well we have love for one another
is there anyone in your friend zone no
no no no no no this is gonna be somebody
new because obviously if that was the
case I would have done it by now so
anyway and actually fall in love with
them in a relationship with you that's
more unrealistic though
you asked me to explain it every time I
say something you just interrupt that's
so you don't get the point so the point
is some if you have respect for somebody
so for example if I have if I'm with a
guy that we respect each other but we
don't have to be in a possessive
relationship where it's like you're mine
and I'm yours no I want it to be a case
of for example we have a baby and every
single day we communicate you can come
over my house I can come over to you as
the baby will grow daddy lives there
mommy looks here you can go to Daddy's
house
you've got a better chance grabbing one
of the guys in the friend zone and
having a kid with him because you know
them you're friends with them and having
a relationship with them listen you've
got literally probably zero percent
chance meeting a guy fresh and being
like hey I know you just met but let's
have a kid
that's Dreamland
right 90 of single mother of single
parent households are headed by mothers
90 of them yes single parent households
are headed by mothers right 63 of Youth
suicides are from single mother homes
ninety percent of homeless and runaway
children are from single mother homes 71
of high school dropouts are from single
mother homes okay 70 of use in operated
institutions are from single mother
homes eighty percent of Youth in prison
are from single mother homes 80 five
percent of children who show behavioral
disorders are from single mother homes
and eighty percent of children with
anger issues are from single mother
homes now hang on hang on a minute
you're saying you want to be a single
mother essentially when and if I read
you these stats and what it's going to
be like for your child generally you
might be
the you might hang on to say oh but it
says 80 which means I might be on the 20
I'm an exception you haven't accepted to
the rule but the rule looks like this
we spoke about at the beginning of the
show I showed you statistics your
rebuttal to me was to use an emotional
response to say oh but you put your
child in that situation yeah but you
know what I never because I did not
choose to be a single father single
fatherhood came to me you the difference
between you and I you are choosing to
put yourself at a statistical design by
putting yourself in a single mother
situation
you said that but you said that though
questions
listen but that's okay it doesn't need
to be living with me that's the whole
point that's the point he's trying to
make
it because the father wouldn't be
present 24 7 in the house with you
and you're saying and you even said that
he would go into yours and he would go
back to there so at what point would you
be together okay okay so let me tell you
they wouldn't be women that have men
that travel a lot for business and do
this
then yeah
that was me my dad traveled for business
and it absolutely I was not in a single
parent home there you go there no I
that's what I'm saying that is still
present even though he's not there
physically no but that's that's why no
no no no it's not the same thing because
I knew my mom and my dad were in love
and when I and I got to see my parents
be in love growing up and even when all
my friends came over and they were they
were both together they'd always say
your parents get along better than all
the other parents and I got to grow up
seeing my parents in love I got to see
them go on dates when I was a kid I got
to where I remember we would like cook
for them and do like a date night and
like surprise them and we have these
family memories we're at Christmas like
we all do the same Christmas stockings
we have family traditions that we do
every year you don't get that in a
single mother home
why did I say bestie because we get on
we hang out yeah
but the main issue is
the intention to not be in a
relationship no one's disregarding how
you feel about what you want to want to
do but you're the arrangement that you
have in your head so that's it yeah
that's it you don't want to be in a
relationship
a child but you still I don't want to
belong to somebody
like where is the obsession with
possession
this is true is that not you wanted to
possess them you want to control that I
don't it all comes down from everything
that we talk about on these shows I have
another conclusion that actually men do
like a woman to be men like to be like
oh
there are so many different
relationships
do you know how many times
one of your best friends are sims just
go and grab one of them
say something about painting this
picture does not take away from the fact
that you're actually in a relationship
there's gonna be Rules of Engagement
yeah you are already in a relationship
so whatever you think you're running
away from you've already created they're
just trying to make it sound like it's
not that exactly and that's why but
that's you're lying to yourself
listen did I not just say somebody that
is like my bestie somebody that we hang
out very well because we do have a
relationship he's not not just a
traditional relationship why would you
know I give them already because I don't
want to be with somebody I don't want to
have to live in love with them well
maybe if
you're not letting yourself fool okay
it's like you want the family but you
don't want the responsibility
you want to be like you want to do
family on easy mode I think I just I've
just got to a point of understanding the
basics of life like the whole thing of
family this decides no we're here to
survive we're here for survival
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible